verrons nous un jour l'autoroute
ville-marie recouverte le maire denis
coderre confie ce dossier à son
adversaire richard bergeron
c'est lui qui pilotera le projet que
l'on souhaite avancer pour le 375e de
montréal dans quatre ans donc françois
korber c'est la deuxième fois en deux
semaines que denis coderre tier 1 points
13 avec richard bergeron
mais cette fois ci pour lui confier un
mandat je n'en ai qu'une de mes
priorités sera le recouvrement de
l'autoroute ville marie richard bergeron
portera le dossier de l'autoroute
ville-marie une cicatrice au milieu du
centre ville l'objectif la recouvrir sur
125 m donc deux pâtés de maisons entre
les rues sanguinet et hôtel de ville
pour en faire peut-être une place
publique ou pour y construire de
nouveaux édifices avec les compétences
approfondies en urbanisme de deschacht
je lui ai demandé de me donner un coup
de main c'est justement richard bergeron
qui avait avancé l'idée de recouvrir
cette partie d'autoroute en campagne
électorale il parlait de coût oscillant
entre 50 et 75 millions ses adversaires
n'étaient pas d'accord avec lui
aujourd'hui pas possible de savoir
combien tout ça coûterait on veut que ce
soit un legs pour 2006 maintenant ça se
peut que ce soit pour finaliser en 2010
mais le travail bonsoir en conséquence
richard bergeron assure qu'il a l'appui
de son caucus pour collaborer avec son
adversaire et il avoue du même souffle
qu'il songe à rester à l'hôtel de ville
jusqu'en 2017
lui qui avait pourtant annoncé son
départ si j'accepte cette responsabilité
si j'ai bien l'intention de
à conduire le plus proche possible de
son terme
il ya un échéancier c'est 2017 c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est vraiment
intéressant